good morning everybody and welcome to
this licensing subcommittee it's 10 am
on the 11th of january 2022
this subcommittee is convened to
consider a new premises license
application in respect
of 64 to 66 high street need a market
applicants and all parties making
representations are entitled to make
representations to this subcommittee um
and
you'll have your opportunity to do so at
the appropriate time of the hearing
the hearing itself will be in the form
of a an informal um hearing um led by
the the chair of the the subcommittee um
and and generally speaking there will be
a report from the licensing officer
outlining the application
the applicant will then be able to make
his submissions to the subcommittee
followed by
anyone present who's made a
representation in respect of the
application
there will be opportunities to ask
questions
of
our after each uh presentation but i
must remind you that there are questions
um on clarification on what's been been
said
and then the applicant will have an
opportunity to sum up at the end and if
the subcommittee have any further
questions to ask them then
then the subcommittee will go into
private session to make the
determination and uh
all being well the determination will be
made
at the end of this this hearing so what
i'll do now is i shall move on to
the
over to the chair um there's no election
for the chair as councillor kathy
guthrie is the chair of the the full
licensing and regulatory
committee
so chair over to you
thank you very much indeed so welcome to
this virtual meeting of the licensing
subcommittee i'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to youtube and will be
capable of repeated viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are consenting to being recorded by
the council and the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded
virtual meeting etiquette
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair so
please await your turn
may we have absence of um apologies
please
non-received chair
thank you do we have any declarations of
interest from the committee members
council wrapping young i can't hear your
response
have we lost connection with cancer
epping young
his um
picture seems to be flickering for me is
it the same for you yeah
that's why i'm wondering if we've lost
connection
are you there
he got up to leave the meeting i saw him
exit his screen
there he is
cancer wrapping young um you've missed
the declaration of interest by
councillors
do you have any declaration
declarations of interest can you unmute
yourself please
apologize chair i had to switch off
those other hi-fi so i could get a
better signal
that was what was the issue i know
you've had problems before thank you um
so i have no declarations of interest
thank you
um so i'll now make the introductions
we've all started speaking so my name's
kathy guthrie i'm the
chair for the subcommittee and for the
licensing committee
we have council paul leping young who's
just
got his electronics working properly
thank you very much good morning to you
paul
good morning councillor guthrie and we
have councillor gerard brewster good
morning to you gerard
you're muted
we've got to get used to this again good
morning councillor catherine um yes
you're sliding out of our picture a
little bit as well so the members can
see
so the office is in attendance you've
already heard from nigel dulu who's our
legal officer morning nigel
good morning chair
and we have the licensing officer kay
sanders if you make yourself known
please good morning chair
and licensing officer catherine greene
please
she's not with us today chair nobody i
beg your pardon i thought i could see
the thing there beg your pardon
licensing officer kerry chandler you're
there please
good morning chair
thank you
and assistant manager food safety and
licensing joe wyatt she's also not with
us this morning i believe chair ah right
okay
but we do have the governance officer
karen sayer i can see you there good
morning good morning and um beth isn't
with us either right okay
we've got mandy doing the technicals as
i
pointed out earlier so for the public
that uh that are listening in mandy
smith is our um expert in driving this
um technical work forward for us so
thank you mandy
so may i now ask the applicant um to
introduce yourself and if you're
represented um please make the
representative uh allow him to make the
introduction so if you'd like to switch
on your videos and your microphones and
we can see and hear and speak to you
thank you if you'd like to do that
it's robert jordan here i'm representing
the applicants and the dps will also
represent the applicants as well so i'll
speak first and the dps will speak after
me
thank you and is mr robert mcginnis is
that who is the dps that is correct
can you just make yourself
please
good morning can you can you just put
your video on so that members of the
public can see who you are as well
because we're looking as if we're all in
the chamber together
good morning to you good morning
so if you'd now both like to switch off
your videos and your microphones you've
made your introductions at the moment
but i will
ask
um did we not introduce our
yes that's what i was just about to ask
we need to see catherine bell if i may
please good morning
good morning to you
good morning
yeah and you are speaking as
i'm speaking as a resident of 76 high
street newton market
and is there anyone else are you aware
of that wishes to speak today
sorry i can't hear you your microphone's
off
we'll get you see your microphone's
still off
i'm not speaking on bit i'm speaking on
behalf of myself and nobody else yeah
lovely thank you very much indeed and so
if you'd now like to switch your video
off again nick we get used to all these
buttons switching on and off eventually
it's it's quite um
challenging
well done thank you very much now um
does
anyone
want to well we've already heard there's
a spokesman so that's robert jordan
thank you very much um are any party uh
wanting to withdraw the application or
representation
um speak if you wish to withdraw thank
you
i'll take that as a no so we'll continue
on with the meeting
so
to the licensing officer which will be k
have there been any requests from the
parties for permission to call witnesses
no
thank you
have any parties wish indicated wish to
present any documentary evidence or
material
no chair um only apart from what's
already been circulated prior to the
meeting thank you very much indeed thank
you
so if i come to the applicant please um
can you advise me of the time that you
are required to present your case if you
would please
um
be less than 10 minutes i'm assuming
you've received the supporting documents
training programme and documents that we
sent in
we we have indeed
my colleagues and so
ten minutes or they're about absolutely
less than 10 minutes so right if you as
you receive those documents we don't
need to go through those again no and
can i ask um catherine bell how long
would you like for your presentation
please
10 minutes please 10 minutes that's
lovely thank you very much
so we move on to the hearing now um so k
licensing officer can you re present
your case and oblique la sub oblique 21
3 and summarize the matter under
consideration for us please thank you
thank you chair this hearing is to
determine an application made for the
grant of a new premise license made
under section 17 of the licensing act
2003 by premier retail limited for
premier 64 66 high street need a market
ip68 aw
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 5th november
2021 and a copy of this is attached to
the report as appendix a the application
made has been subject to the statutory
consultation period as prescribed by
regulation the notices advertising the
application have been on display at the
premise and published in the east
anglian daily times
on the 24th november 2021 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form attached as appendix a
the operating schedule steps proposed by
the applicant to promote the four
licensing objectives are listed in part
m of the application form
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representations which have not been
withdrawn the subcommittee will be aware
that its consideration is confined to
the promotion of the four licensing
objectives and the need or commercial
demand for licensed premises are not
considerations for the licensing
authority when discharging its licensing
functions
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act with the
view of promoting the licensing
objectives which are the prevention of
crime and disorder public safety the
prevention of public nuisance and the
protection of children from harms
subcommittee will also be aware of human
rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 for the applicant
and articles 8 and 1 of protocol 1 for
those raising representations when
determining applications for the grant
of a new licence
the license authority have received no
representations from any of the
responsible authorities
there have been nine representations
received made by other persons which
include local residents businesses or a
residence association this is attached
as appendix
to this report
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take
such of the steps if any it considers
appropriate promotion of the licensing
objectives to grant the license subject
to conditions which are consistent with
the operating schedule accompanying the
application
modified to such extent as the authority
considers appropriate for the promotion
of the licensing objectives any subject
and subject to any mandatory conditions
which are included in the license
or to exclude from scope of the license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates or to
refuse um to specify a person as the
designated premises supervisor or to
reject the application
for these purposes conditions of the
license are modified if any of them are
altered or omitted or a new condition is
added
any party agreed by the decision taken
by the licensed authority and respect of
this application has the statutory right
to appeal to the magistrate support this
concludes my summary thank you chair
thank you very much indeed for that so
i'll now come round in order to ask
people if they'd like to question kay so
mr jordan do you have any questions for
the licensing officer
uh no
thank you uh mr mcginnis do you have any
questions for the licensing officer
no thanks no thank you and um catherine
bell do you have any questions for the
licensing officer
no i don't thank you
thank you and so i now come on to the
councillors councillor epping young do
you have any questions for the licensing
officer
can you unmute yourself
sorry chair i do have one question i
just there was one of the
representations indicated that the
notice had not been posted uh
for an appropriate amount of time i just
wanted clarification that indeed the
notices had been imposed in the relevant
places for the relevant amount of time
can the officers answer that
the agent did confirm that the notices
were displayed and um
a photograph was sent in
i'm sorry could you repeat that please
okay sorry the agent for the applicant
did confirm that the notices were
displayed um for the correct amount of
time and he sent in photograph of said
notice being displayed
can i just ask nigel de liu is that
normal that is the applicant who sends
these details in or should the council
have checked this
no that that's normal procedure
thank you
um
and councillor brewster do you have any
questions please
i don't have any questions at this time
madam chair
thank you councillor brewster i just
have one question it's really for
clarity so that members of the public
and everyone here today can be assured
of this can we confirm that the police
were aware of this application
sorry can't hear you need to speak
without your mic sorry yes chair they
are a responsible authority and receive
a copy of the application
and we didn't have any response from
them at all no
okay thank you very much that's just for
clarity
right so we move on
so we now move um to mr jordan if you'd
like to present the case please thank
you very much indeed
yeah thank you very much chair um i'm
just glad the supporting documents have
been submitted so i won't um repeat
what's said in the supporting documents
but it's quite comprehensive
with child protection policies and staff
training
and various documents that are needed
for
staff to sign they've been trained so
i'll deal directly with the
points made in representation
first to clarify there's not a 24-hour
delivery or collection of alcohol
proposed
the proposed hours are 6 a.m to 11
p.m for the
um
alcohol
opening hours and distribution of
alcohol for delivery if if
needed the licensing officer suggested
we apply for a 24-hour license if we
wanted people to be able to pay for
alcohol online at any time because
obviously people will pay when they put
the order in uh
if there's a website etc etc so they
could pay any time so that was the
reason for the 24 hour license so i hope
that clarifies the issue
um
drunken people currently in the area but
that's nothing to do with the applicant
as they do not hold a license in the
village and they've got their strong
training program
and as regards parking's responsibility
of people to park legally
we don't think that's a licensing issue
and where they do not park partly the
internet authorities can intervene
in fact there's a new highway code
regulations coming in force at the end
of the month it would appear
so there's no 24-hour delivery and
premises are not alcohol-led
comprehensive range of products is
available
uh there'll be daily litter patrols that
keep the area immediately outside the
premises clear of litter
that provide bins as far as um outside
as far as planning allows and not to
cause obstruction on pavement of course
challenge 25 policy
so we believe the license should be
granted as submitted as there's
no
objections from the or authorities uh
obviously the applicants wish to
not to upset any numbers so
obviously it's not in their interest
they're investing quite a lot of money
in this
as i understand it premiere store
uh so it's a completely new refit by
uh established shop fitters so it's it's
it's not just opening up you know
willy-nilly there's a whole shop fit
going in there with a whole range of
products
alcohol would be one of those products
um
i think the gist of the
representations against this were the a
lot was mentioned of limitless hours
supply of alcohol and we've clarified
this is not the case
we don't believe any additional
conditions would be needed to be imposed
as obviously responsible authorities
have looked at the conditions
as we believed to impose conditions um
to prevent the harm it should be
self-evident harm would occur
the
co-ops got till 11 p and we think i'm no
doubt the license officer clarify that
on the website
because i think the co-op was mentioned
but not that that's relevant to this
application but i think they have a
license to
11 pm most days
and also apart from sunday 10 30 sunday
and also there seems to be a lot of
licenses in the area
that have licenses till 11
according to the website and then some
have got longer hours so we don't think
it'd be a case of people
going into the premises after they've
had too much to drink in a public house
and
pestering these people for alcohol
um
so i think i'll we put the training
pressure i don't want to go on about
that um
we can't really speculate what will
happen as the threats case would say
uh noah schwarzer authorities have made
representation uh stress out alcohol
will only be appropriated to the
contract from the premises from 6am to
11pm
uh as i said the only reason for the
24-hour license
was because licensing suggested that
would be needed to allow payment
online
it's not in the family's
interest to upset the neighbours
and
various family members
um have
other members have got shops etc
so no additional conditions being
requested
and we believe no additional conditions
should be added to licence and it should
be granted as applied for
um obviously
if
you know
the residents were to
you know see a problem
the dps would be more than happy to
to to take on board anything they
they've if they've got a problem with
anything i mean he's experienced i i
mean he's going to speak
briefly shortly but um
i think he's experienced is just past
his aplh exam so i think he was a he's
going to explain to you that he was
in charge of licensed premises under the
old regime before the personal licenses
were acquired i believe but i'm i'm
going to let him deal with that so i
just hope we've um dealt with that and
robert mcginnis can
put forward
as he's going to be the uh
proposed the proposed dps so i'll leave
it at that actually
thank you for that um i i before i go
around the table i do have a question um
myself
how many people will be in the store
after say 8 p.m at night
oh at least two
we wouldn't want a condition on that but
there'd be at least two after 8 p.m
um
but we wouldn't want to condition on
that
to uh i mean sometimes people have to
pop out
and possibly
just asking what what the yeah and
obviously they'll have to take a break
they'll still be in the back or
something like that yeah but there'll be
at least two there might be more than
that but i would say at least two
yeah and um if
we need to sort of ask the um legal
officer this next question but
would you object to a restriction of um
i know the officer has recommended a
24-hour
license would would um the applicant
object to restriction to
only during opening hours and i'm not
sure whether nigel might want to jump in
and say we can't ask that question or
not so if i ask nigel first and see if
you're allowed to respond
thank you well chair any condition needs
to be
necessary and proportionate
it may be that if you do consider that
such a condition is is necessary then
you may
um impose a condition that states that
face-to-face
sales and and transfers of alcohol can
only take place during the designated
opening hours of six to eleven um which
is what the the applicant is is
suggesting anyway but if
if you feel that's necessary and we'll
discuss that and we'll go through that
um that that may be an option
right and can i ask the applicant
whether that would be something they
well whether they'd be happy or not it
would be our decision wouldn't it
yeah
yeah yeah
so
we need more basic science at the moment
do you think
just i mean it's just for um there seems
to be
well
a discrepancy among various legal
advisors whether payment at one o'clock
in the morning in the morning
constitutes a licenseable activity or
not
it would only be payment it wouldn't be
anybody going to this physically going
to the shop or collecting the product it
would only be
um
leading the product
yeah i think the the um
the team and the nigel officer and the
nigerian the uh legal officer will
probably tell us that that is a legal
requirement for those purposes uh to
designate it in that threat would you
agree nigel
yeah yeah so i'm just sounding out as to
what might be okay so um
thank you very much for that for the
moment uh council rapping young do you
have a question um for mr jordan
uh thank you madam chair uh i think at
this point i just have one question
which is whether
um this shop is going to employ
anyone under the age of 18 at any time
um they can't employ anybody under the
age of 18 to serve alcohol obviously um
i i think they'll um apply with all the
rules and regulations
that would be involved with employment
but they wouldn't want some
um
younger people on the premises after
sort of
six o'clock in the evening or too early
in the morning
and and only during the the restricted
hours that they're allowed to work i
wouldn't want a restriction on
them being employed but obviously they
wouldn't want to be there after i would
say six in the evening certainly
with um
at least two or three members of staff
to supervise them but only within the
regulations i wouldn't want to commit
them to not employing
did you say
over 16 or under 16
sorry
under 18 under 18 so obviously they
would be above 16 years old or whatever
that legal limit is for employment now
but certainly not after 8 pm or after 6
pm really and certainly only within the
restrictions of the very restricted
hours
i think on
the 16 year olds working now but they'd
have to go by that they've not told me
they're employing anybody at 16
um as far as i know they're all going to
be over 80 but the dps could probably
tell you a bit more about that because
he'll be in charge of the premises
thank you and councillor brewster do you
have any questions for mr jordan
speak up you've got your microphone
muted
we've got to get our buttons right right
off you go
um i think madam chair the question that
you asked was one that i was i'd got a
concern about and and that has been
answered i i feel so
i think uh no i don't have anything else
to ask
thank you for that
um and now i come to the um
nigel would it be the officers first and
then the
um
catherine or catherine first
i have no questions myself um if the um
uh
yeah if the other representative here
wants to make any questions then yes so
catherine bell do you have any questions
for mr jordan at this stage please
yes i do
can i put my camera on and yes please do
yes yes we'd like to see and hear you
thank you
thank you
um
mr jordan refers to several elements of
his proposition for uh you know why this
is a
unacceptable application
he refers to well hang on a minute i
don't want to go through the whole thing
what is your question no my question
well i'm just giving a backdrop is my
question was really around that he has
made no differentiation
between
the days of the week
so not any mention of sunday has even
been put forward
which i'm slightly shocked about because
this still isn't a question uh mrs bell
if you will have an opportunity to make
all your representations you need to in
a few moments
my question is what about sundays
uh
i think
the
co-op has 20 to 30 hours finished on a
sunday and not that that's relevant to
this application
but um according to the
um what i got off the website i think
there's sunday as is sorry
that's incorrect they close in the early
evening on a sunday the co-op hang on we
don't want to debate now would you we we
will sort that one out for you um well
that's on that that's the mistake on mid
suffolk district council's website and
they've got a license till 22 30. it
stakes on there but it could be out of
date but um
there's
no
problem in the closure time of 22 30 on
a sunday
which is
i think is um would be acceptable
on page 24 nigel
hang on i don't want you to start
debating at the moment can i just have
clarity nigel on page 24
there is um ours premises open to the
public it says six till 2300 hours so
sunday is mentioned
that's right yeah the application is um
the same hours for four seven days of
the week that's the application so
sunday is mentioned it's just not satis
we'll hear
catherine bell we'll hear your your
issues regarding that in a moment just a
moment
so really the questions any any actual
question that you have for mr jordan
please
um i think i'll wait now until i've made
my representation um some questions
might come on the back of that thank you
very much yeah that's fair enough that's
excellent thank you very much indeed so
we now hear from um yeah so i've just
noticed that the licensing officer has
her hand up
actually oh yes okay k and then
counselor king young okay apologies i
just wanted to clarify um the co-op king
william street need a market do actually
hold a license monday to sunday um six
o'clock in the morning until 2300 hours
across the board monday to sunday just
to clarify that point
thank you very much for that
and if our website's wrong can somebody
check that out for us please so that
that's in the ring as well cancer
wrapping you on
thank you madam chair um with regard to
appendix a
of this documentation um there is a on
page 25
um a number of uh commitments by the
applicant in terms of how
online sales are going to be managed and
and staff trading and so on at what
point
in these proceedings
can we ask questions with regard to the
those
particular issues on page 25.
well nigel i would say now would you not
yes um
i just wonder whether you want to hear
from mr mcguinness first because then
you'll have
all the applicants representations and
it may be easier to hear from him and
then we can ask all the questions
perhaps both of them if there's anything
you want to to catch up with on that
sure thank you
um i do notice catherine is coming back
but it really must be a question if you
would please because um it's not the
debating area as i'm sure you understand
so is yours a question again your hand
is up
to you there we are yeah yes so
it is the question
my question to mr jordan is does he
intend or do the new
um
shopkeepers intend to keep
the hours of six till 11
um
exactly or six till 10 30 because that's
not what the co-op do so my question is
do does this um applicant intend to keep
to those hours for opening um because
whilst um
uh case sanders has kindly pointed out
the co-op had the same licensing they do
not keep to those hours
legitimacy of opening or closing other
than the uh signs at the the times
so um if mr jordan would just like to
answer the question although i think
that's probably best to mr mcguinness
but if he'd like to say build the shop
keep to whatever times are appointed
um will they keep it up
yeah i can answer that firstly on the
delivery
section and the conditions offered in
delivery we understand that is a common
um
agreement with major operators on the
delivery of alcohol so that comes from
which we
can't we can't tell exactly
who's agreed those conditions but we
understand and i've been informed by
licensing officers that that is a
condition that's widely agreed with
a major
uh delivery uh companies so it is a
standard condition um i can't say that
the
if the at the hours granted is 11
p.m then they obviously
may open till 11 p.m
um
but um that's all i can say on that
really and obviously they won't be
restricted if the license is granted
till 11 pm so we can't really i can't
start debating on their behalf when
they'll close and when they won't close
okay i think you've answered the
question to to to the degree that we can
at the moment
right so if we can now move on and ask
mr mcginnis um can you take your hand
down catherine please
um if we can ask mr mcginnis to give his
presentation please
hi can you hear me yeah sure
um
previously previously i was a bar
manager for uh
over 20 years in belfast so i was
licensed on the previous regime um
this
this establishment i'll be the dps for
this premises um obviously
strict staff training um cctv images
in regard to the actual opening hours of
the premises um
i haven't got a crystal ball but um i
don't foresee the shop opening at 6am
possibly
6 37 a.m um and regarding closing times
closing times would probably be
half ten so
uh the reason why the license was
applied for six a.m to l that's just can
i give a better scope um
staff training
um
all staff will be over 18 years of age
so they'll be
legally entitled to serve alcohol
um
all
all aspects of
um licensing will be adhered to
obviously
see how things go we don't we can't
forecast what percentage of sales the
alcohol is going to partake but there
will be numerous other products
in store um
alcohol would not be the main reliance
of sales
so
that's basically all i have to say
all staff that will be
serving behind the card will be over 18
years of age um
in relation to that previous question
thank you very much i'm sure some
questions will sort of
get some more information from you um i
would just ask a question um
will people be living on the premises
there
there's two there's two uh
flats above the premises a minute which
are attended by
uh private individuals um
do they have access to the shop no
no they
they have
they have uh
they have an interest at the rear of the
property um okay and um do you have uh
will you be nearby should there be an
incident
well i i i live i live in ipswich which
isn't too far away uh north capture so
i'm living so it's not too
not too far away and i will be there
um
regularly and what sort of um other
items will you be selling newspapers
sweets food there will be freezer things
what what sort of things to give a
flavor of what you're yeah there's um
there's chest freezers going in there's
um stand-up fridges going in
um
obviously
premiere's a well-known brand um
they have new numerous numerous retail
units throughout the east of england um
and
if anybody goes in there they can see
what
sort of
lines they're selling um
there's gonna be
a
slush puppy sort of machine put in there
um
sandwiches you know food on the go type
thing i think i think this is a a
general convenience store
premiere good general convenience store
so selling a wide range of products
really yeah thank you um you know there
might be
it could could be pay point that could
be cash machine that could be
they'll have it fitted out to to give
the full it's quite a reasonable size
store as you can see
um but it's a premier i mean okay
just a bit now yeah
yeah good good good convenience store
right comedian still thank you it's just
i'm not okay with them um counselor
epping young do you have a question for
mr mcginnis please
uh yes i i do um
good morning mr mcguinness uh welcome
um
so do i take it that you will be
providing the training that's uh
mentioned in your application
basically myself on a
exterior
training firm will be coming in
to uh
i've i've had experience i've been the
retail manager
in uh
and
various shops as well so i do have
experience um
a lot of the modules that the staff will
be doing will be
on online um
and obviously
there'll be they'll be training
six months every every six months
there'll be retrend
fire regulations
licensing regulations just just to keep
them open with any changes that are
afoot
okay and will there be regular
inspections
ad hoc inspections in the shop to ensure
that
[Music]
the
cctv system will have uh
over 30 days of recording um on hard
drive so um
against the instant book as well so any
any instance will be recorded and then
can be um
checked back on the cctv system
okay if i could just move on to the
um
area of online sales
so
um
people can order alcohol
from uh this from this shop via an
online website um
i what i want to know what precautions
there would be to actually stop an
underage person ordering online
um well perhaps i could answer that
i spoke to the applicants and we put in
those conditions it will be as per the
conditions on the um on the application
well well accepted conditions by
major operators and accepted by the
police we understand in negotiation with
major operators it will be as per that
condition
so it should be sufficient um you
it seems to be sufficient with with with
the bigger companies um multiple
companies um
that's my in information from liverpool
council
that this is was
i think this is
one of those i can't quote liverpool
council they'll be coming back to me but
uh i
i remember this was a licensed officer
who gave me some uh
uh what what what had been agreed
because i've dealt with
just for clarity perhaps i'll just
direct the members to it's on page 25
um under the um of appendix a under the
general um conditions there are a number
of conditions there that relates to
dealing with um online sales
um
and i believe there was
some other information perhaps with with
the additional documents as well
yeah well and that nigel i mean in in
section c
um it does talk about
the adoption of an age verification
policy throughout the whole process of
operation
um
but i failed to see how anybody can
actually stop someone
um
ordering online if they're underage
i don't really do
we can go through the conditions um but
there there are procedures of of
requesting i identity when alcohol is
being delivered as well i think that's
been included
let paul and nigel sort this out please
so
i can see the uh point about delivery i
i have a question about that also
um but i don't think um anyone has so
far really satisfied my question as to
how we're going to stop an underage
person ordering online
there is physically no way to stop
someone sitting in a house remote from
the
the premises
um making an order when they're under
age there are procedures in place as to
when a delivery is made that the person
they deliver to has to provide identify
identification that they are the person
that made the order and that they are
the person that's old enough to make the
order over 18. um
um
yeah
i think there are various places i know
when i i've in the last year or so when
i've made orders i've had to stand at
the doorstep with my my driving license
um
even though i know i sometimes look
under waiting but you know
even me i've been asked to show our
identification and um
i i believe looking at the conditions
it's very similar um we can go through
those in in private session if you have
any concerns uh we can go through those
if you feel anything needs bolstering up
then you have the ability to
include further conditions if you feel
they are justified proportionate
and required
thank you very much nigel uh i shall
leave the rest of my uh issues until
then thank you
thank you councillor hopping on
councillor brewster do you have any
questions for mr mcginnis
uh i have just one actually madam chair
um i'm a little confused over the
licensing bull area
which the whole
uh
ground floor appears to be having the
red line so
is is do you have a specific place to
keep the alcohol and and uh
um because
there must be some security about that
as well out of a thought
um the reason we
always um
for the last 10 years have been
licensing the whole of the alcohol but
the whole of the
area
is so that they have
the freedom to exactly what you're
saying
uh move it if they feel that it's not in
a great place but it will be in view of
the counter or cctv
but
uh
as it's never
hardly ever been an issue it's not going
to be the whole of the shop covered with
alcohol there'll only be a percentage of
the shop covered with alcohol
but it just gives the
applicants the freedom to move
the alcohol
i've done this on every application for
the last 10 years
and
it's
maybe
one or two have come back to to to ask
that to be altered so we always do that
because
well yeah we always do that um
we've had
sometimes an order comes in
and an order has to be put on the floor
before it's put on the shelf and this
has caused uh an issue with a licensing
officer walking in and saying you've got
alcohol displayed on the floor when it's
just
you know quite a big order coming and
placing it by the counter so they can
see it before they put it on the shelves
or moving around we don't want that to i
know it sounds silly but most licensing
officers wouldn't be an issue with but
some
you know just how there's a bit of
there's a there's a there's an outro of
alcohol on the floor it shouldn't be on
the floor uh so we licensed okay i think
we've covered that point thank you
councillor bruce do you have another
question no i don't that was my only
question but uh i've been looking at it
and it's just a little bit confused as
to what you know what was happening with
that area but i can understand that it
does need to be um
movable basically yeah um just before i
come and ask catherine um bell for her
questions if she has any for mr
mcguinness um but i do note that mr
jordan has been replying to most of
these so mr mcginnis doesn't seem to
have the confidence of answering some of
them or whatever um
maybe i'm wrong in that assumption mr
mcguinness so i apologize um but hey
would you um
just ask your question before we ask
catherine bell please yes okay
thank you chair it was just to clarify
um the issue around the plan licensing
would normally recommend um for an
offside shop to
cover the whole shop with the sale of
alcohol
for the very reason mr jordan said if if
they were to move things around they
would then have to turn around and
submit either a minor variation
application or a full variation
application so
we advise that to save their money um
okay that's very helpful i think um so
thank you for that okay and now
catherine bell if you'd like to ask your
question for mr mcguinness who's sitting
patiently waiting thank you who is the
key holder for the alarm going off
please
who who's the key holder
um
if the alarm goes off late at night in
thunderstorms which they always do right
um
the premises is not it's not complete
yet um so
that will uh
there's definitely decided well it's a
bad question so i think yeah it's the
one at the moment
the thing is that's the question that's
been put in if you can't answer it we'll
debate it when we go out well obviously
the dps
have to be a key holder i mean that's
without a doubt but other
other nominated people depending on
staff levels will have to be nominated
as well they may be nearer to the
premises and may be able to attend
quicker
but um
obviously the dps will be a key holder
um
these are
experienced operators
and uh you know they have got other
shops
sorry in relation to the the previous
question regarding the um
the ubereats orders for online
um
robert's more experienced with
that then i i am that's why he was
answering on my behalf because
if we couldn't see him and you were
sitting there looking up yeah
that's that's so that's all that's all
that's all a new um that's all new
things new area for you yeah yeah but
you got you okay
i have one another question please yes
how many how many burglaries
thefts and crimes have been reported at
premier stores this in the last three
years please i don't think that's a
relevant question do you nigel
why not no well we're looking at the new
premises here um
no other premises there will be stats
catherine please don't interrupt the
legal officer if the applicant is
prepared and has the information
prepared to give that information then
i'm happy for him to answer um but i
will advise the the committee to give
the relevant weight to that question
exactly
all i will say is this has been before
the police the police have the
statistics the police have made who are
the experts on crime disorder that's
under guidance 182
so
they have made no representation on this
application
they are happy with the delivery
conditions they are happy with the
conditions we've offered have made no
comment on
extra security or crime crime scene
prevention they've not made any any
other suggested conditions
um
we feel this is a good application and
we just need the answer to the question
that catherine asked you haven't got the
details and um we've heard the response
that you've given on that
um catherine do you have another
question at all
those are my two key questions thank you
they have not they have not neither of
them have been satisfactorily answered
but thank you
yeah thank you for that
um
so now i'm just running around the
offices are there any further questions
that the officers wish to ask for mr
mcginnis well thank you chair
right okay
thank you for that
thank you
so now
catherine if you'd like to give your um
presentation um we we need to hear from
you with all the issues that you
obviously have got to tell us in your
words please if you would
thank you very much indeed um firstly i
just wanted to clarify
sorry you've gone we can't see you
have we lost connection with with
catherine
hello sorry i don't know what happened i
i don't know what happened there i do
apologize don't worry it comes and goes
the internet is always reliable
right please
yes uh firstly in order to um and and as
it's my presentation i hope i can do
this firstly um counselor uh brewster
madame chair seem to be confused when i
put forward a point about the co-ops
actual
opening times and i do believe that was
a relevant part of my um presentation
because
i and why i asked one of my questions
about the intended opening times because
i have the opening times in front of me
here of the co-op and on sunday it
closes at six in the evening
and i think this is a very relevant
point because
i think the um
key presentation issues i have reverse
around public nuisance point of
the concerns here that i have and those
relate to another point which has been
made very light of but i think is a very
substantive part of my concern
the road going through needham market is
a very widely used road in fact so much
so that the a14 is being diverted
through here at the moment for an eight
week period by mid suffolk district
council or by suffolk county council
actually
the road is being diverted through here
which means that we have serious levels
of heavy traffic going through the
village
this compounds and is approximate cause
of one of the issues that i have
the co-op has four parking spaces at
king williams street
the other co-op in the village has its
own parking lot which by my last count
had at least 20 parking spaces available
this means that there is no interruption
to the flow of traffic
as part of the application being made by
the um applicant here
the aggressive nature of drivers who are
looking for parking and
are being treated by the people who wish
to drive through the village is to be
seen to be believed
i'm not sure how many of you sitting on
the committee live in needham market or
live in the high street but
just to give you some context around
this and i must apologize i had a major
operation on on friday i am sitting here
in some pain
at the moment to put forward my points
and if my voice should take you if i
take your time
i'm actually not very well but i feel so
passionately about this that i put
myself out
and and i took exception to what
appeared to be a little bit of scoffing
at one of the points i made
so please bear with me i'm doing my best
now
what's happened is there's been quite a
lot of criminal damage in the village
i have lost 250 pounds worth of
ornamental tree um pots
of hanging baskets have been removed and
stolen
my christmas tree was stolen some very
beautiful pots that i put in the high
street in order to
make my frontage really beautiful to
show pride in my community and my
village have been kicked and smashed
that is heartbreaking
but it is a sign of the times we live in
where we can put whatever rules we wish
to in place
we can quote whatever laws
i am an ex-police woman
i know the law
and i know what it's like to try and
control
um anti-social behavior and public
nuisance
i know how difficult that can be
suffolk county uh the suffolk police
force currently have three police
officers at any one time covering this
area
i've now been told there isn't a
nominated key holder who can come if
there is a problem i've asked a very
valid pro point on the attraction of
money being in a store which is open at
night which becomes a target for robbery
and for burglary
i have been given no substantive or
reassuring answer to those questions i
they're both valid questions and no
answer has been given
the co-op operates um with its own
parking
the parking issues in needham market are
they're terrible
the amount of shouting and screaming and
speeding motorists in this village is
now untenable
i've approached my counselor k oaks on
numerous occasions to explain that i
had to shout at a car the other day
doing 70 miles an hour through this
village now
the reason that is contributory to these
licensing hours is this
when people are trying to pull over to
park
they are disrupting the flow of traffic
and they may only want to pop in to get
some beer or some wine or to pop into
this new store okay
but in popping in they are going to
exacerbate
and elevate
the issues around there being no parking
available with this store
now moving on to the other issues around
the criminal behavior
i think that this village has the right
to enjoy peace and tranquility of an
evening
this high street does not have any other
store open in it during the period that
this store is proposing to open which
means currently residents have the
enjoyment of at least a little bit of
peace and quiet because there aren't
excessive people coming to a premises at
night
during the day the post office receives
numerous visitors but that's to be
expected this is a a small village which
has a very super facility to have some
shops here i am not disputing that
my rationale
is that
this store
is operating outside the current
operational
um
sort of
personality of the community
it is an addendum to our current
expectations as residents
as residents on a sunday for a store to
be attracting traffic up and down this
high street when at the moment we don't
experience that means that we now have
to tolerate if this is granted
further inconvenience to our already
uh burdensome experience
of speeding cars
anti-social behavior vandalism that i
have absolute category proof of
you can come i could show you pictures
of my smash pods that have been kicked
litter
alarms going off as a police officer i
know that when the thunderstorms come
that alarms go off all night in shops
all over the place you have to go and
try and find a key holder
um
the applicant lives in ipswich so it's
not on his doorstep
it's online
these these inconveniences are on my
doorstep
and they're on the doorstep of lots of
other very decent very lovely residents
of needham market and you are the
custodians of our quality of life
all of you on this committee are the
custodians of our well-being
and i put it to you that as the
custodians you need to look at the
opening hours of the co-op and grant a
license based on the same opening hours
that the co-op as a community-focused
provider
of similar services to premiere adopt on
behalf of our community
and they should be proud of that and
they should be proud of that because
they live in harmony with us
and i have nothing against the applicant
personally but you are about to decimate
our peace and quiet on a sunday and i
take exception to that
and i am imploring the councillors on
this committee to hear the passion in my
words here and to know they come from a
place of not egregious fictitious
um comments that i'm making to be
deliberately awkward but because i know
it is going to undermine our community
thank you very much
thank you for that passionate um
uh um
review of the situation as you see it um
and i do understand it
um if you are happy to to keep your
video off and compose yourself and
get a drink of water or something and
we'll give you a few moments do the um
officers
do does counselor evan young have any
questions
for katherine bell if we just give her a
moment
uh madam chair no i have no questions
for for catherine thank you at this
moment
right councillor brewster do you have
any questions
sorry we can't hear you
there you are no you've done it that's
better um no i mean i i do understand
where catherine is coming from um but i
don't have any questions
right do any of the officers have any
questions for catherine bell please no
chair
no
no
no no thank you
thank you thank you madam chair for
listening to my concerns i really
appreciate the uh review being held
thank you
no not at all um and and i appreciate um
the issues that you've raised i mean we
used to work in need of market and we
used to shop in a market
and so we know the particular shop that
you're referring to but not your
particular home um and and it sounds as
though you've had a very unfortunate
experience but thank you for coming
along
um
so i think um
if there's no further questions then the
applicant has any questions sure oh
yes um mr jordan would you like to ask a
question and catherine you're quite
happy to leave your video off if you so
desire
i i don't
care
no
counselor jordan
i mean mr jordan
uh no no questions oh i thought you said
you had i beg your pardon i'm sorry um
and does mr magnusson have any questions
mcginnis sorry
no question thanks
sorry about that that was just an
interruption um
right
so we now ask um
the um
applicant to sum up please
i think that's right sorry i just got
disturbed there nigel that's where we're
at at the moment isn't it just something
yeah closing submissions uh if the
licensing officer has anything just to
clarify now now's the time for the
license officer to do that and then for
the closing submissions from the
applicant yeah the one thing i would ask
of the licensing officer because
catherine bell did bring it up can we
really have clarity
on i know the co-op isn't our um
applicant here
what they are allowed to do and what
they actually do because i think that's
a difference um that we need to just
consider so could kay could you just
clarify that and i'll write it down as
you speak
yep i can clarify that they have the
ability on their licence their permitted
hours on monday to sunday
zero 600 hours in the morning until 2300
hours
and basically
uh from um catherine bell they don't use
those out and they are but that is
they're within their rights to do that
that's not our remit but they know but
so that we can get clarity on what we've
been told so that catherine can be
assured that we are understanding what
the issue is
and so they seem to close um at
what was the time
6 p.m on a sunday and they don't open
until 8 00 am and they close at 10 p.m
on every night other than sunday and i
have a copy of that documentation
yes lovely that's really helpful thank
you for that so we're all clear on that
when we go into our session um so nigel
i think
if we now ask um the applicant to sum up
for us yes i'll do this i'll do the
summing up uh thank you you can put your
video on we can see who you are i'm
sorry
there you go technology i'm not up with
it um
so
we don't think parking is a licensed
activity and all the hearings of it's up
to people to park correctly but um
i'm sure they can encourage people not
to be
obstructive as regards licensing there's
obviously a review procedure should any
issues
we think the license should be granted
as
um submitted
specifically since most of the
objections seem to be regarding crime
disorder and the police have not made
any comments on this and guidance 182
says they are the experts
and
they should be
um obviously key holders i've not been
scoffing at any points raised so i hope
that's
not not um
our suggestion we've been scoffing at
any points raised um
it's not nice being in hospital for a
length of time
as i know um
and obviously
key holders they have to be provided to
the police the key holders have to
have to give the police the name
uh an address of the
key holders because otherwise be no
point in having the alarm
um if it goes off too many times they
don't um
and they can't raise anybody they would
um
stop attending
so
in my experience
the training program's there
so it's quite clear what the training
program is
and
you know it's not opened yet it's not
fully fitted yet so all all safety
measures have been put in place
once it's um
finished and i was going to make another
point which i've seen forgotten about
and the actual
i mean i think
it says that our id
procedure will be undertaken at the
point of delivery
and that seems to have been accepted um
by major
companies and the co-ops not really
relevant to this application but um we
would hope that um
our clients would not be um putting in a
disadvantaged position as regards the
co-op as a as they're making a big
investment so i would hope there's not a
different rule for
my clients than the co-op but
obviously they don't
go to
11
sunday
10 30 would be okay um on a sunday to
for end of license hours
um i saw what i've got to say really i
think
i hope i've addressed the points made by
the
representations
but park is not a license for the issue
that's been proved many times
um there's a review process
and the police haven't made any any any
representation
um obviously these issues that the poor
lady's been experiencing
it's not good is it
i've lived in various areas and it does
vary and it can be a nightmare in some
areas and some areas not much of a
problem
but um these are not related to my
client and they're not related to sale
of alcohol
um it seems it's not related to the
co-op co-op is
apparently not related to the co-op
although that's not relevant to this
application
so
what what the vandalism is it doesn't
seem to be related to to alcohols uh
from off licences
um i'm not gonna say anymore really i
think it should be granted as as
no more conditions
uh on that license
whether they're open to 11 i don't know
it would depend on trade money they're
expecting about 15
of trade to be alcohol the rest to be
non-alcohol products 10 to 15 percent
trade alcohol
depends on um
whether they that they seem
reasonable hours and hours are already
granted in the area so they're not and
and also the
i think mentioned these a lot of other
pubs and whatever they are there seem to
be open
um
after 11 and license players after 11
so
okay for sunday to come down to 22 30.
we cannot can't say any more really
that's it really
thank you very much indeed um
so i think we've all had sufficient time
for questioning and um
and hearing everybody's points of view
so on the basis of that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public
it has resolved that
under section 100a brackets 4 of the
local government act 1972 the public are
excluded from the meeting for item 6 on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in part 1 of schedule 12 of the
act on the grand set out in regulation
14 brackets 2 of the licensing act
2003 brackets hearings regulations 2005.
may i have a proposal please
happy to propose madam chair and a
second of please
happy to second chair thank you very
much so in that case what will happen is
members of the committee and the legal
officer will adjourn to another room in
effect so all of you may remain where
you are and we will come back once our
deliberations have been made so thank
you for that and we will now leave and
go to our next one sorry to interrupt
check can we just um check with mandy
that she's paused
okay much for your patience um i will
now hand the meeting over to nigel who
will come up with the conclusion of our
deliberations thank you nigel okay thank
you everybody for waiting um as you may
gather the the subcommittee have
deliberated long and hard over this
matter um they've considered the
representations made orally at the
hearing today um but also the the other
written representations uh made to to
this uh application
uh there are three areas that i just
want to cover
um
that were the main considerations that
the first matter was the um operational
times of about the stores um and the
subcommittee quite rightly have decided
those weren't not relevant to their
decision making the decision today was
made on the the application itself on
its own merits and the impact that that
application would have on the licensing
objectives
the second main issue that they
considered was the issues regarding
traffic and parking and again
they acknowledged that
there are issues with uh traffic
particularly at the moment with diverted
traffic coming through the town and
parking problems um
they don't necessarily agree with the
applicant that this is not an issue
for licensing
the existence of a licensed premises
may have a direct impact on
parking in the immediate area which may
contribute to antisocial behavior and
aggressive behavior
in that respect
however
they've also considered that there was a
store previously cited at this premises
although it wasn't open for those hours
but during the the day time and the busy
times there was a store there that would
have required parking as well and so
they're not satisfied that there is
sufficient um evidence relating to the
traffic and parking that would have a
material impact on the licensing
objectives to refuse the application on
that basis
with regard to the anti-social behavior
and vandalism this was
more of a concern for for the members
they have real sympathy for for
catherine bell and for the um other
persons who made
uh written representations in respect of
this matter
however the difficulty that the
subcommittee have here is we're dealing
with a new premises which has no track
record and that therefore there's no
evidence of um anti-social behavior or
violence emanating from the premises
and having considered it very carefully
and also having looking through the very
carefully the um the council's uh
licensing policy at part six which
refers to licensable hours
um still there's not enough information
at this time for them to actually
validly refuse the application on that
basis
obviously if there are if there's
evidence in the future that
there are problems directly attributed
to these premises there is an option to
review the license and the license may
be called in at any time
if there are if problems exist
so
again the um
the subcommittee feel that there isn't
any
information at this time for them to
actually refuse the the application
they
do wish to impose a a condition
um and that is that
um face to face and in person sat in
person sales of alcohol will only take
place between the hours of 6 a.m and 11
p.m
monday to saturday
and 6 a.m to 10 30 p.m
on sundays
so that's the the decision of the uh the
subcommittee
any person the applicant and any person
who's made representations
to
the subcommittee
who is not satisfied with the decision
or has an objection to any condition
imposed may appeal to the magistrates
court within 21 days of receiving
written notification of this
decision
and
i'll just hand back to the chair to
close the meeting
thank you very much indeed nigel and
thank you to everybody um for their
attendance today
and i do hope that
both the
applicant and the
resident
will be comforted that a lot of care has
been taken over this but that they can
work together
um and so with that and i wish katherine
bell a healthier recovery
and so i now close the meeting thank you
very much